The Alt Shift X Podcast has three episodes
out now. There’s an interview with C. M.
Kosemen, the creator of that crazy sci fi
story All Tomorrows. And there’s a two-part
interview with the authors of The Expanse.
They’re both really fun
conversations, and you can watch now at the
links below. The podcast is on YouTube and
Spotify and every podcast app.
Alt Schwift X has also been busy. There’s
a seven hour long video all about Song of
Ice and Fire theories, and the one hundredth
episode of the Game of Thrones Abridged Podcast
came out. There are a couple of video essays
about Bojack Horseman and death and stuff.
And there’s now an Alt Schwift X gaming
channel playing Dark Souls and The Binding
of Isaac.
Some people think that Alt Schwift X is the
same person as Alt Shift X, but there's little evidence
for that fan theory. Alt Shift X is professional and
concise with research and citations, while
Alt Schwift X is an unscripted rambling hot
mess – which is why we don’t usually promote
Alt Schwift X on this channel. But some of
these videos you might enjoy.
There’s also another, stranger channel called
Random Article. It has some kooky storytelling
stuff, and some quote-unquote “horoscopes”
that have an almost improvisational tone.
If you like weird stories, you might like
that channel too.
But the only true official Alt Shift X side-channel
is Alt Shift ZZZ, which has readings of old
books, like audiobooks. The latest video was
The Call of Cthulhu by H. P. Lovecraft. There’s
also some SCPs, some non-fiction, some religious
texts, all sorts of stuff.
All of these channels and videos are linked
in the description below.
Finally, check out our sponsors, CuriosityStream
and Nebula. CuriosityStream has thousands
of documentaries about science and history
and nature, and Nebula has exclusive content
from YouTubers like TierZoo, Volksgeist, and
Alt Shift X. Nebula’s an independent platform
where we don’t have to deal with YouTube’s
algorithm and demonetisation, and can try
new kinds of content. You can get CuriosityStream
and Nebula for a year for just fifteen bucks
at the link below.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to the Patrons,
including Katie Matthews, Jordan Talbot, Vincent
N Mapanao Jr, Zack Krafsig, Torb, Michelle
Fairfax, and Funky goalie. Cheers.